well look as far as this virus is
concerned one of the things we've
learned is it's far better to go
early than to go uh too late so whatever
i may think about the government's
tearing system it's really important
from midnight tonight we all follow the
rules we're going to be in tear through
we've got to abide by the rules that
being said
i think the government needs to realize
the consequences
of them putting london in territory as
far as our economy is concerned
there are many pubs bars restaurants and
cultural venues
that have spent a lot of time effort
energy and money making their places
coveted secure and when they close
tonight
many of them may not reopen which leads
to billions of pounds of money being
lost from our economy
and potentially hundreds of thousands of
jobs being lost
and my concern is that the government
appears to be retrofitting
an ineffective tearing system around an
issue
of the virus spreading and i'm not sure
if it'll make much difference to
the virus spreading and that's why i've
been calling on the government to do
much more in that age group where we
know there's been the biggest increase
in the virus a 75
increase in the last we've got numbers
those aged between 10 and 19
many of them don't go to
pub's bars and restaurant i've not seen
a child of 10 11 12 or 13 in a pub bar
or restaurant and so my concern is that
the
blunt instrument of tier 3 won't do
what's needed
which is to reduce the virus quickly can
we therefore
ask you to be explicit i mean do you or
do you not agree with the government
decision to put london
into tier three i mean we've said it a
few times in the program this morning it
seems somewhat counter-intuitive
to move 10 11 million people into the
top tier
you know seven or eight days before you
know they're all heading home for
christmas
i think the government's policy of going
from london in tier
two then to three then tier
zero for five days then tier three and
potentially in january a national
lockdown
doesn't make sense and so i've been
lobbying the government with council
leaders in london
on a cross-party basis for them to
various things to
ensure we get a grip on the virus in
london for example
making sure we have mass testing
available in schools
for those children who may have the
virus not realize it for example
at those schools that aren't covered
safe haven't got the mass testing
maybe closing a few days earlier because
those very same
children who could have the virus and be
asymptomatic will be hugging
grandma grandpa next week and
potentially passing the virus on
another thing we're lobbying the
government for is to give flash support
to those businesses being required to
close tonight
because unless they give additional
support these businesses will go bust
how how understandable is the
government's decision to move london to
tier three when
it does appear that the greatest strain
being placed on the nhs
isn't happening in central london isn't
happening you're just south of the river
from where we are
it's happening in essex it's happening
in hartford church it's happening in
kent
but the problem this virus doesn't
respect boundaries
whether it's borough boundaries or
whether it's county boundaries we do
know
uh a couple weeks ago we were seeing
particular problems the northeast of
london
and the boundaries of kent and essex but
the virus spread so
quickly it's like imagine a swimming
pool and there are lanes in a swimming
pool
you throw a die in the swimming pool
that die won't respect one lane in the
swimming pool
and so that's why it's important to have
a one london approach which i fully
support
we've got one nhs serve in london one
police service enforcing these rules
one transport system but you're right
it's the neighboring counties as well
which have an impact on our city that's
why
whatever we think about the government's
decision uh we've got to follow the
rules uh
tonight to make sure we can reduce the
chances of the virus being
spreading but it is nonsensical to go
from tier three
uh to tier zero and then back to tier
three when we know in january
according to previous years the nhs has
the busiest month
and this january is my fear is the nhs
could be
overwhelmed and the real kick in the
teeth for some people would be the fact
that we know the vaccines are being
rolled out
many of our older friends are receiving
the vaccine
imagine how heartbreaking it will be if
these older people who could receive the
vaccine and live long fruitful lives
uh don't receive the second dose catch
the virus over christmas
and god forbid lose their lives in
january february uh
mr kenneth i'm going to hand you a
metaphorical grinch outfit right now i
mean
from what you're saying isn't it
possibly the best idea that we
we cancel christmas that we close that
window
you're not being grinch at all i think
what you're doing is following the
science and actually what we've seen
across
the the europe and across the world is
those countries
that are more effective at dealing with
this virus having short-term more
restrictive
measures that helps health and wealth
so look at germany and netherland
they're not for example relaxing uh the
rules over christmas for
five days allowing three households to
mix up unlimited numbers
uh which could lead to the virus uh
spreading
sorry can we just can we just be
explicit are you saying
that we should not have the christmas
window that the christmas window should
be closed
i heard the government say yesterday
they haven't ruled out further changes
i would encourage the government to look
at their rules over christmas we have to
have a four nation approach you can't
have one rule for london
one rule first of the four nations
because people are family across
the nations and what i say to the
government is i'm not sure you've got it
right in fact i'm i'm sure you haven't
got it right
in relation to the relaxations over
christmas if they don't change the rules
my message to your viewers is we're
under no obligation
to do all that's allowed there's no
reason why you have to
kiss or hug an older relation if you are
seeing members of
other families in your home who are
older even if they're younger open your
windows allow ventilation
because none of us wants to
inadvertently pass the virus on
um i wonder if we might just briefly
dwell on on the clash that it appears is
forthcoming between
at the education sector yourself and
indeed
at greenwich council it is the labour
party's position as well as the
governments that the schools should
remain open as
far as as humanly possible given the
negative impact that we saw
on young people in the first lockdown
why do you feel that closing the schools
even if only for a short period of time
is a good idea
i want schools to be open uh we've seen
the consequences of schools closing from
march until
september every day school closes it's
bad for our children
they've been heroic efforts from our
teaching staff but here's the problem we
know that the age group for which
there's been the biggest increase
in the virus spreading is those aged
between 10 and
19. the last week for which we have
numbers
showed a 75 increase in the virus
amongst this group
these children go home give the virus to
mum or dad
and these children will break up on
friday and potentially be hugging
grandma grandpa
next week potentially passing the virus
on so what i'm saying to the government
is they need to make sure that our
schools and colleges have mass testing
to test their children
and staff and the good news is some
schools and colleges have this i visited
one in wolfram forest yesterday
who have mass testing so that's a covid
safe school my concern is there are some
schools
many schools that aren't covered safe if
it's the case
these schools can't be made covered safe
over the next couple of days
those schools should one or two days or
three days
before the normal breakup close early
have more online lessons this week and
maybe
open one or two days later in january to
enable mass testing to take place
because my concern
is these children aren't showing any
symptoms they're passing the virus on
and we will we'll get a grip on this
virus which will be catastrophic for
those who catch the virus
who are older or have underlying health
conditions and also potentially the nhs
which could be overwhelmed in
january